last question today's from Sophia Sophia
said hey what conspiracy theories are
you guys still surprised that some
people really believe the moon landing
one is pretty high on my list the idea
that that was staged that's when that
comes to mind vaccines cause autism is
one that has been so thoroughly debunked
that that one comes to mind but what
about you the paul the paul mccartney
died thing is another one contrails is a
big one for me that one and of course
the picture we put up the the 911 thing
although for some reason what what makes
a conspiracy theory more i don't know a
more prolific than others the 9/11 one
is not going anywhere
it's also more recent though you know i
think that that's another factor it's
more recent than JFK or whatever else
jason any particular ones that when you
hear people mention them you say really
you still think that well I'm gonna tell
you the Loch Ness from Monster is real
so is Chupacabra but what is the deal
with Chupacabra it's like it's some kind
of goat like animal right no no it eats
goats oh yeah I think Chupacabra means
goat sucker actually literally in
Spanish it does yeah yeah well it's um
it's people would capture what they
thought was a chupacabra
yeah marry these dogs that it seems to
be some type of dog and it has fangs and
no one's still sure if this is what's
killing the goats but the goats have
Fang marks and it's it's a weird thing
but a lot of people are just saying that
these are just dogs that have mange or
something and that I don't know I think
that it's we can divide conspiracy
theories and the two types there's the
ones it tends to be more political ones
that are more motive inspired like
here's the reason why the moon landing
would be faked and it's to create this
perception of superiority over Russia
during the space race Cold War etc here
is why 9/11 would have been allowed to
happen usually the conspiracies aren't
that it was faked but that it was sort
of allowed to happen and here's why
geopolitically it would have made sense
the Loch Ness monster Bigfoot Chupacabra
types they're less based on motive right
they're more based on stories where
everybody's reports are similar and this
comes to I've actually read about
anal probing became a common thing
involved in the alien things like how
did it like you know people say you know
I don't necessarily believe in alien
abductions but it's sort of weird that a
lot of people are talking about being
Lois really reacting to this about being
anally probed and there must be
something to that I don't remember what
the explanation was but there's some
reason why that became a theme and you
can actually trace it back to some
particular you know reason in the
literature why that's a thing yeah yeah
it's funny they convey Lian's can
somehow teleport you up to their ship
that came from another planet but they
still have to stick something up your
butt to get readings yeah that doesn't
really make sense to me I mean I don't
make sense to you I mean I assume that
most of them wake up the next morning
and there's have a sore feeling in the
certain area their body so I mean to
them it might make sense anything else
we want to mention as far as conspiracy
conspiracy theories that so surprised
you know I think that's all of them one
that sometimes people will mention
casually to me and then we'll just sort
of move on is stuff related to like
Illuminati build the burg etc and
because you know like the Bilderberg
Group exists and whatever that's one
that a lot of people feel like it's not
really a conspiracy theory it's just
sort of hey it's obvious that there is
this uber powerful group that is
actually controlling us and the entire
concept of Democrats and Republicans is
controlled opposition to make it seem as
though there's two factions that are
warring bla bla bla bla bla and
sometimes the most dangerous ones are
the ones that are more difficult to
debunk are the ones where they're based
on an infrastructure that does have
verifiably real pieces but then the
extent to which people believe it is
what's sort of escalated and that those
can be tougher to talk to people about
yeah well the Bilderberg Group is real
yeah yeah and they have meetings every
year and the meetings are very private
and there's no media allowed and then
there are no cameras and all of that
stuff yeah so it's easy to run with all
right send me your thoughts if we're
missing any what are your favorite
conspiracy theories that you just can't
understand how people still believe